there's a very good article on medium by
a guy named Eric Medlen which talks a
lot about the upcoming midterm elections
but it also points out that there are
these three recent stories that have
gotten a lot of attention in the United
States two of which have been pushed
hugely by right-wing media one of which
has been reported on correctly by all
media but still all three of these
stories are potentially huge
distractions from the fact that we can
start going in the direction of fixing a
lot of the problems we're experiencing
right now merely by voting on Tuesday
and I want to be really clear here
because sometimes Pat when we say a
story is a distraction people hear that
it means it's not an important story and
that's not what we mean by a story is a
distraction and also even when we say a
story is a distraction that doesn't mean
that it's a deliberate distraction by
someone in pushing or talking about that
story so let me give you an example
Trump's fake tax cut this has been kind
of going around for several weeks now
you might not even have heard of it
because many shows haven't covered it
because it's fake and the idea is that
Trump floated that the Republican Party
may Doohan other-- tax cut so-called tax
cut I mean a lot of people's taxes
weren't actually cut by the first tax
cut that they may do another tax bill
which he's calling a tax cut by the end
of 2018 it's not gonna happen like it's
it's just it's simply not going to
happen if you look at the fact that the
midterms are next week and then you've
got a lame-duck session and you have
end-of-year breaks for lawmakers and the
fact that there is no such bill in
progress at this point in any state that
would be remotely close to actually be
voted on to be debated voted on in past
in 2018 it's totally fake okay and
Donald Trump talks about this at rallies
all the time like it's some kind of
imminent tax cut it does not exist okay
it's not gonna happen if indeed
Republicans keep control of the house
maybe they will pass another tax bill in
2019 or 2020 but there is no imminent
bill right now the way Donald Trump is
trying to claim it is a distraction and
even discussing the
merits of another tax cut could serve to
distract from the reality that people
just need to go vote between now and
Tuesday
okay Story number two the immigrant
Caravan this is a real story in the
sense that it exposes the underlying
xenophobia and in many cases sort of
nationalistic jingoism that exists on
the right they are selling it to us as
this imminent invasion of criminals
coming in to flood the United States to
commit crimes to rape women but the
reality is there's no invasion this is a
group of people seeking asylum it's a
group whose size is dwindling every
single day as they get closer to the
us-mexico border even Shepard Smith on
Fox News said nothing is happening and
if this actually did become a so-called
attempt to overrun the border that we
have huge law enforcement and it's just
not going to be a big deal it's nothing
nothing is happening does that mean we
should ignore the story because it's not
happening no we actually need to push
back against the talking points related
to the story but you've got to remember
that if Democrats go out and take
control of the house and take control of
how government money is spent all of a
sudden we retake a lot of the control
over how government resources are used
when it comes to immigrants number three
we talked about Trump's idea that was
learned about over the weekend of ending
birthright citizenship by executive
order it's a real story
I believe that Trump genuinely wants to
do it but it's not happening before the
election it's not at all likely that you
even can do this via executive order but
what do all three of these stories have
in common they are distractions from the
fact that your vote Tuesday can change
the direction of the country it's really
important to understand this Pat because
I feel like this is where people
sometimes lose the thread a story
doesn't have to be a deliberately
planted ploy to distract to effectively
serve as a distraction and that is what
I am trying to
people it doesn't mean every single one
of these stories is crafted as a
distraction we can't let our eye be
taken off the ball and that's why iPad
have just been talking every single day
lately about you've got to go vote
because that will give us way more
control over all of these issues then
talking about the stories now and you
can't help but think if these
distractions are going to work my
instinct is that the birthright
citizenship stuff and the migrant
caravan stuff isn't going to necessarily
sway independent voters I think that the
people who are in support of Trump are
going to stick by him but he's not gonna
pull over any people in the middle to
vote for Republicans in the midterm
elections based on those two issues the
middle-class tax cut thing maybe that
could sway some independence people who
aren't so knowledgable of the fact that
Congress isn't even in session right now
but they'll take Trump at its at his
word that I think could be effective now
all of that being said we do need to
understand that number one increasingly
it doesn't seem like Democrats are going
to take over the Senate everybody should
vote consider every individual race
fifty-fifty but the numbers are not
looking great for Democrats taking over
the Senate but that's okay because if
you take over the house number one you
upend the entire legislative agenda of
Republicans and Trump
that's huge number one number two the
house has oversight over the executive
branch and has the power to do all sorts
of investigations that might actually go
somewhere and there's much more than
just Donald Trump to investigate to be
perfectly frank with you Trump's cabinet
is an extraordinarily corrupt greedy
self-aggrandizing group of people that
we need to be looking at very closely
winning state houses and governor's
races on Tuesday could deflate a ton of
trumps climate change craziness because
governors and state legislatures have a
ton of say about how their states will
deal with the environment but you've got
a vote whether you see it as a
referendum on Trump whether you see it
as a way to protect Robert Muller
whether you see it as a way to get
trumps cronies in the House and Senate I
don't care why you do it but you have to
vote and not be distracted by issues
that
are important but they're not going to
get resolved between now and Election
Day that's the really important thing
today's program sponsored in part by
Blink is comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n